زهره بيجوم الى بنغلاديش بحثا عن الامان
بعد ان واجهت الحمله العسكريه في ميانمار
لكن هذا ما تواجهه الان حيث اشتعلت
النيران في منزلها المعقد في مخيم كوكس
بازارد للاجئين
لقد عانينا من ماساه مماثله في الان فقدت
منزلي هنا وفقدت كل شيء
الناس الذين يعيشون هنا يقولون ان الحرائق
اصبحت متكرره بشكل متزايد في المخيم ينتمي
هؤلاء الى اقليه الرهن المسلمه في ميانمار
الذين واجهوا السنوات من الاضطهاد في
بلادهم هناك العديد من متطوعي الروهنديا
الذين تم تدريبهم من قبل الامم المتحده
ووكالات المعونه الاخرى للتعامل مع مثل
هذه الحاله الطارئه
متطوعون مثل يستخدموا درجات بخاريه صغيره
مزوده بخزانات مياه وحاولوا اخماد الحريق
نجهز الطعام والماء لاولئك الذين شردهم
الحريق العديد من العائلات التي فقدت
منازلها المؤقته تعيش الان في العراء
لقد هربت مع اطفالي تحول كل شيء الى رماد
وفقدنا كل ما كان لدينا
يقول المفاوض المسؤول عن مخيم اللاجئين ان
الحكومه ستساعد المتضررين
لقد اتخذنا بعد القرارات المتعلقه باعاده
التاهيل الاشخاص الذين فقدوا منازلهم
المؤقته تقدمنا الاطعمه الجافه في البدايه
وفي وقت لاحق قدمنا الوجبات الساخنه
اعادت النيران تسليط الضوء على المعاناه
والصدمات التي يواجهها كل فرد هنا يوميا
على الرغم من الصعوبات يحاول الكثيرون
اعاده بناء مساكنهم في المنطقه هذا الحريق
هو تذكير بالتحديات التي تواجه اللاجئي
الرهنديا انهم عالقون بين الوضع الخطير
على نحو متزايد في بنغلاديش وواقع سياسيا
جديدا في وطنهم يقوده نفس المجلس العسكري
المسؤول عن الحمله القمعيه التي اجبرتهم
على الفرار تنفير تشادري الجزيره كوكس
بازار بنغلاديش